this is a going to be a communications
forum which is brought to us by compared
to media studies in the center for
future Civic Media my name is Chris
csikszentmihalyi I direct the Center for
future Civic Media which has been going
for a little under three years now and
we're dedicated to developing
technologies for kind of democratic
processes in Geographic communities
really with emphasis on kind of new
media and new forms of social action
enabled by digital platforms and we're
where we really see ourselves as you
having feed in a bunch of different
areas we come out of a long tradition in
comparative Media Studies in the MIT
Media Lab of thinking through
technologies for journalism and kind of
reportage and my own research group
specialized in data transparency and to
some degree whistle blowing as well and
so you put that together and you have a
fairly good excuse for why we invited
these two very skilled and talented
people so what L what I'll do is I'm
just going to introduce them each one by
one reading off of BIOS that you could
probably get online I actually only one
of them and but but then they're going
to start by giving short lectures of
about 10 to 15 minutes no more I'll ask
some questions at the end of that and
then we have a full hour for you guys to
ask questions so what I'd encourage you
to do is take careful notes because
right now it's more of a frisbee day
than a lecture day in the afternoon as
one of our speakers pointed out and in
fact was was asking if we could just
cancel but I said no no no frisbee for
you so so so there aren't that many
people in the audience here so it would
be great if you were ready to ask you
know in-depth questions i'm pretty sure
that you'll have time to get follow-ups
afterwards so we'll start with linda
Fanson immediately to my left Linda is
has a background in journalism started
out as a journalist in small towns of
Wyoming piecing together newspapers with
hot wax and border tape
and baling wire and baling wire no no
bailing wire and a not just hot wax but
also a partnership a close partnership
with the readers these rural news
organizations are incredibly tight with
their readers and technology has changed
a lot in 18 years since she got started
in journalism but her devotion to jerz
ilysm and the deep connection with
communities has not in January 2008 she
joined minnesota public radio american
public media which most of you know and
in a project called Public Insight
journalism an initiative that's become a
model for making use more relevant and
collaborative and for reconnecting use
rooms with the communities that they
serve at the heart of it is a network of
83,000 as of now but it keeps growing
83,000 public sources who share their
insights and expertise to broaden and
strengthen news coverage inside analysts
use online game simulations and
collaborative tools to help newsrooms
around the country identify emerging
stories define major news projects and
engage citizens after i did in weekly
papers in wyoming fanden spent a dozen
years as a reporter and editor for The
Salt Lake Tribune where investigative
and storytelling skills were frequently
honored she worked briefly for Newsweek
before moving to Minnesota and continues
to write a monthly column for The Salt
Lake Tribune she's taught and lectured
on journalism the University of Wyoming
where she earned a BA in journalism in
1992 so thank you so much I'm for
joining us and next we have Ellen Miller
who's the co-founder and executive
director of the sunlight foundation a
washington-based nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to using the
power of internet to catalyze greater
government openness and transparency and
really the preeminent organization doing
this in the United States she's the
founder of two other prominent
Washington based organizations in the
field of money in politics on the center
for responsive politics and public
campaign and I have to say that I first
engaged with CRP when one of my students
was doing a big government transparency
project and found that the CRP database
was absolutely the deaths database on
politics and money and he was basically
building a system that merged it with a
bunch of other databases by a bunch of
other organizations and then we got a
cease and desist letter
but on following up we we they were very
generous they had real concerns and we
addressed them and so a phenomenal
organization but she keeps producing
them one every five years six years or
so it's just incredible and then that
she's a nationally recognized expert on
transparency and the influence of money
in politics sure experience it and
that's recognized as an expert on
commenting on it not participating in it
your experiences in Washington advocate
for more than 35 years spans the worlds
of nonprofit advocacy grassroots
activism in journalism ms Miller's work
was recently featured in Washington
magazine Fast Company who called her one
of the most influential women in
technology wired who said that she's one
of 15 people the president should listen
to and The Chronicle 53 and many more
she's also served as decorative deputy
director of campaign for america's
future publisher of tom paine calm and a
senior fellow american prospect she
spent nearly a decade working on Capitol
Hill to great effect and she blogs
regularly at sunlight foundation calm so
without further ado we're going to have
Linda open and give a presentation about
Public Insight journalism so thank you
well thanks I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here as Chris said i
started my journalism career in bunch of
small weeklies in Wyoming and I always
said that people read the paper to find
out if we knew what they knew which was
absolutely true so I joined NPR American
public media a couple of years ago and
the Public Insight Network Public
Insight journalism was in full swing it
was founded about six or seven years ago
by some really smart people bill cling
Michael scholar build views and Burke
and a couple of other folks who are
still on our staff and technology has
changed a lot since then I mean seven
years in today's world is like centuries
with the changes that were we're seeing
both in media and technology but the you
know the base there's this basic premise
behind pij many of you if you've heard
of it it's a big database of sources but
it's really grown into something much
much more it's a it's actually almost a
community of practitioners if you will I
mean we're now embedded in so many
newsrooms that we sort of see this as a
great model for networked journalism and
community engagement and and so I just
going to take a little time to walk you
through a little bit of the particulars
but maybe the focus on how its kind of
reshaping news gathering in new and
newsrooms around the country whoops so
the so the principles behind pij are
pretty simple that people out there in
the community have a lot of different
expertise basically through their
experiences or maybe they're have
authority of expertise and they really
want to share it with us they and if we
can tap into this if we can collect it
if we can tag it categorize it and
infuse it into our journalism on a daily
basis we can make that coverage richer
and deeper and more importantly more
relevant so what's an example of someone
who might be in the network well you
know an airline mechanic with 20 years
experience of working on Boeing 737s is
going to have a certain amount of
knowledge about the air worthiness of
that plane maybe even more so than an
FAA instructor who's examining data
and reports because they've actually
generated the reports so those are the
kind of people who are in our in our
network as well as FAA instructors
actually Elizabeth Warren knows a lot
about bankruptcy but someone who's been
through bankruptcy has different kinds
of insights insights they could share on
on those issues and so when people hear
their voices and their stories reflected
in news coverage they connect with it it
becomes more relevant and read over NC
builds trust and Trust is something
that's sorely lacking in the media today
but again piaget i think is is more than
that it's actually grown into the system
of engagement if you will and the idea
is that as people share their first-hand
insights and and such and they can
become more informed about their
communities and become more engaged and
therefore more able to solve problems
and in the case of what we're talking
about here today that builds a much more
robust democracy and this is a principle
that's fundamental to public media which
is why it's not surprising that this
whole system sort of took root at a
public radio station so how do we build
this network well we do it through a
variety of means we we do it through our
websites so every partner that has pij
embedded in its newsroom will have a
website we will create web survey forms
for the people in the network and we'll
post those links on the web sites will
do call outs on the radio and steer
people to it you see news orgs all the
time doing this on facebook now and
Twitter they tweet out a question hey
NPR National Public Radio is looking for
people aged 30 to 45 who just got kicked
out of their homes or under foreclosure
we just happen to have a system that
captures it all in a database and
therefore it's searchable and it kind of
changes the way you're you can approach
journalism we also reach out through you
know let's see it looks like these
things are kind of all on a click here
sorry they used to be automated again
social networking social media we use
that as well and we also have developed
a number of serious games that both work
in this area of government transparent
providing data and information to people
but
end of each of these games people have
the option of joining the Public Insight
Network providing some demographic
information and then comparing their
results I'll talk a little bit more
about budget here on minute we also meet
people face-to-face I mean digital tools
are great but when you really want to
have engagement with the audience and
the public sometimes you have to meet
them where they are not everyone has
access to the internet or a computer to
fill out a web survey so it's really
important that we do a lot of
face-to-face work so but the important
thing is kind of what we do with
people's insights this is what counts
this is why people sign up when you have
a database that's searchable by zip code
by passion interest expertise occupation
you can quickly reach out to people and
get insight if you're familiar with the
story of the airplane the Northwest
airplane that overshot the minneapolis
airport several months ago and it kind
of became a big national story we were
able to turn to our database really
quickly not only identify pilots but
pilots who fly the highly automated a320
plane and in this case we found someone
who had nine years experience flying the
plane who had was now an FAA consultant
and had written his master's thesis on
the consequences of boredom in the
cockpit it was incredible we got him to
write a commentary for the website so
well most news organizations were sort
of talking about you know what happened
in this instance and how dare you you
know how dare you let people get on
their laptops and have conversations we
actually had some some real insight into
why that's actually a good thing we also
are able to let people's voices sort of
be heard on their own terms so in this
case we wanted to find out how on the
50th anniversary of Sputnik how that
event had changed people's lives we
focused on the scientific community we
got a survey out we distributed it we
contacted people who have connections to
scientists and we were able to gather a
ton of really rich stories that both
aired on the radio became a slideshow
and now we have 250 physicists in the
network as a journalist you might think
wow I need to talk to a physicist but
think how it changes the way you do your
job when you go I type 2
150 physicists what would I like to know
from them it's a much different process
when you when you have concern ilysm
softened done with this catch and
release method reporters interview
people they're done with them they may
contact them another time but it's only
when they need something from them
because we regularly reach out to people
we make it a point to try to contact
people in some fashion once a month in
the network we're sort of maintaining a
connection and relationship to them over
time and this results in a level of
trust that they will tell us things and
talk to us and go on the radio with
stories that might be otherwise hard to
get in the case of Oregon Public
Broadcasting they're able to tell
stories about their talk to people that
the media often just talks about so
they've done series on stories of women
who've had abortions they've talked to
people in bankruptcy they've talked to
people who've been in the penal system
and this is all made possible by this
continuous relationship that we build
with the public one of the sort of i
think really maybe not surprising but
most rewarding parts about Public
Insight journalism is that it often
reveals stories that you didn't know you
were looking for so in this case kuow in
Seattle the reporter wanted to do a
story about condominiums people who are
renting and they got kicked out of their
apartment buildings because they were
going to go condo and because we were
open enough about the questions we were
asking what we got was someone who was
used to live in a mobile home park and
two years earlier the entire community
was uprooted for a development that
never took place because of the economy
so this reporter wasn't where they were
looking but it was a much better story
in their in their opinion oftentimes pij
can help us get ahead of the story in
this case we had been talking to
military contractors and soldiers about
the tensions and experiences that they
have mostly testing a hunch and so we'd
been gathering information stories from
people so when the Blackwater scandal
broke we had a really rich contextual
story to tell about these people whereas
most media organizations were still sort
of focused on just the scandal and we
were able to add a lot of context to
that mainly because we were had our ears
to the ground and see
piaget also has the element to really
make government more transparent and
accountable but maybe not in a way that
you've traditionally thought about New
Hampshire Public Radio decided that they
would use the Public Insight Network and
those tools as a way to reach out to
their they have something called town
meeting in New Hampshire I don't know if
they have it here in Massachusetts to
but they reached out to all these town
administrators and they said you know
we'd like to have some information about
what's what are your budget priorities
what's on your budget agenda and they
got incredible response because they
people saw this as a public service they
put it on a website and there would be
towns and people could click on it and
see when the budget hearing was and what
the major issues were but what it gave
the station was an incredible amount of
information and they were able to spot a
trend in how that basically the i think
it was though that the towns were
actually discouraging reliance on
property tax and they could not have
seen that had they not had this
tremendous response and be able to see
all that data in one place in in in this
instance we had we'd been talking to a
lot of people about the economy people
have been telling us that they there
weren't a lot of jobs out there with
benefits so when the state issued its
regular job vacancy report we said well
hey what we'd like to see is how many of
these jobs have benefits and has that
changed over time do you track that and
they said yeah we do but we've never
actually parsed the data that way let us
get back to you and when they did they
were really astonished to find that
there have been like an 80% turnaround
in several industries are 180 degree
turnaround where eighty percent of the
jobs used to be benefited and now only
twenty percent of those jobs were
benefited so sometimes just talking to
people and listening to them can teach
you what questions to ask and in this
case push government to think about the
data they're collecting in a different
way I mentioned before that i think the
public insight journalism is incredible
catalyst for collaboration we've worked
some with ProPublica we we did a big
healthcare project with them where we
queried our network and their network
about what people's most pressing
pressing health care needs are they then
took that information and they looked at
the bills before Congress and they wrote
stories about how those bills
or would not meet the the health care
needs are stated by ordinary citizens
around the country we've also got an
ongoing project with him right now
around unemployment and unemployment
insurance that's that's really
interesting and gathering some good
stories I should say that the Public
Insight Network because it's
self-selecting and it's not
representative of the country is not a
polling tool it we don't do surveys we
don't say forty-five percent of women
aged 30 to 45 care about X it's really a
way to just kind of tap into what is
important to people and what they're
concerned about and what their
experiences are and find their expertise
and sort of bring that into our into our
work and so if you think about other
ways that you can sort of use these
tools in this case it will talk about
government accountability it's a
different way it's not that we started
with a lot of data it's that a reporter
wanted to do a story about health care
in the prisons and after we started
talking to people we found that the real
story was about all these abuses that
had happened and taken place after a big
riot in the Chino prison in Southern
California because technology aren't
accessing the web and filling out
surveys in prison we actually found
people who had relatives who were
imprisoned and they took written
printouts of our survey into the prison
and had the prisoners fill them out and
then we brought them back and entered
them in by by hand and this resulted in
an incredible investigative report and
the state is now taking another look at
at what happened in launching a new
investigation because of this work so
this is just a snapshot of some of the
newsroom's right now that have Public
Insight journalism these tools and and
someone dedicated in their newsroom to
doing this work we just signed the Miami
Herald these are mostly public media
Public Radio partners but we do have an
online newspaper in the st. Louis beacon
we just signed the Miami Herald we have
we're in discussions with about five
other major newspapers in the country
and we think that by December of this
coming year with a little bit of luck
and some funding pij might be actively
working in influencing journalism of 40
newsrooms around the country this is
incredible when you think about the
network and of this community of
practitioners not only do we have a
network of
horses we have a network of newsrooms
that could suddenly collaborate with one
another using some of the tools that
both Ellen and then sunlight foundation
have developed to document cloud which
is very interesting application that
allows people to dissect public
documents and make comments so we think
the the possibilities and the the
promise of pij has really yet to be
fulfilled and finally I'll just say that
you know this is just a sort of a
testimonial if you will from marni fry
Vogel she's a longtime journalist it now
started up the st. Louis beacon and
she's pretty hard hard to impress but I
think she'd be the first one to tell you
that the future of news isn't about
cheaper journalism isn't about citizen
journalism it's about better journalism
and and that's really what pij i think
is all about and with that I'll just end
and thank you very much for your
attention thanks that was phenomenal so
now Ellen Miller from sunlight
foundation all right so I confess I'm
the one who suggested the frisbee game
and I want to say to chris that I was
not at the center for responsive
politics when they ordered the season
desist order and you will be happy to
know that all of their data is now
available through an open API thanks to
funding from the sunlight foundation so
things do change in this world for sure
so let's there'll be some slides coming
shortly
progress there we are so thank you
Christopher for having me i have to
confess this is my very first time at
MIT and i just wowed by the architecture
of this building and the student
presentations that I saw this afternoon
it's just it's terrific it will not be
my last visit here so thank you for
having me so the sunlight foundation is
a four-year-old organization that was
designed specifically you use the power
of the Internet to catalyze greater
government openness and transparency and
to provide new tools and resources to
media and citizens alike where we take
our inspiration from Justice Brandeis is
famous adage sunlight is said to be the
best of disinfectants and we're
committed to improving access to
government information by making it
available online indeed redefining what
public information means as being online
and by creating new tools and websites
and using social media to enable all of
us to analyze the information and pull
our collective intelligence in improving
it use of technology as a tool for
transparency engagement and
collaboration is absolutely corn central
to everything we do we've had this a
tremendous luxury of having been born
four years ago so we're not a
long-standing NGO that has had to make a
transition to this new age and it is it
is a terrific luxury our work falls
primarily into five buckets see I'm
thinking springtime and the beach
digitizing data is core and advocating
for government to do the same building
tools and websites on top of that data
to make it easier for journalists
citizens bloggers to use sorry citizen
engagement and is is our fourth category
and the last one is what I think of as
the eating our own dog food category
which is mostly doing media
our selves becoming a media outlet
ourselves digitizing data is absolutely
core to our work we fund core data
providers because they already do it
well the Center for Responsive Politics
the Institute on money in state politics
taxpayers for common sense and several
others and mrs. brings into our for
campaign finance information lobbing
revolving door personal financial
disclosure earmarks this kind of data we
refer to as influence data and it's very
core to our mission to follow to follow
this kind of data we've created new data
sets and I'm going to run through these
quickly we can talk about them later if
you like such as fed spending org this
was the first publicly available free
database of all government grants and
contracts subsidies so scope org this is
a project of actually a project of the
Pew Charitable Trust a project to follow
all government subsidies you've never
been able to search them all in one
place at one time the foreign lobbyist
influence tracker is a sunlight database
which took hand written paper records
and digitized them one year's worth of
these records these are lobbying forms
filled out by individuals who represent
foreign governments creating a database
that was never possible to to see before
unless you wanted to go to the basement
of the Justice Department and you happen
to be in Washington somewhere between
the hours of nine and five so this this
is also a way for us to put pressure on
the Justice Department to actually
digitize this information another site
louis dee be louis DB this is a site
sunlight created that scrapes the eight
or nine different federal documents such
as the congressional record and
executive orders and the code of federal
regulations that is a single search in a
single searchable way in a site called
party time this is a site that actually
tracks the fundraising of
Vince aka parties and so you can follow
them there's party time we actually last
week posted on a google map where the
parties are by the I can't remember
minority leader Boehner and the
second-in-command Hoyer so just to see
if they had any overlaps of parties
there we also created databases out of
information that the the White House is
made available the White House visitor
logs they do put this information out on
a monthly basis but it's really
difficult to search so we created a
database out of it and then you can look
and see whether Patrick a B you could
see his google profile and if we could
scroll over you could see whether he was
listed on several other websites you
could find out actually who it was and
we've created a database out of house
expenditure reports these are office
expenses which sunlight pressured the
house and the Senate to release the
Senate's will come later this year and
you can determine how much money
actually members of Congress are
spending on bottled water in their
office or sending flowers or other more
important kinds of things after having
built and funded a number of databases
our Holy Grail is actually to build a
data repository to bring these data sets
together we think of this as a data
Commons and this is our beta site called
transparency data right now on this site
you can see for the first time any place
a combination this may be the project
you were working on Chris this is all
the state and all the federal campaign
contributions so you can search this
site with someone's name like t boone
Pickens and you can see all of his
campaign contributions at the state and
federal level this week we'll be adding
lobbying contributions I mean lobbying
expenditures so you can see whether he
was ever a lobbyist whether he hired a
lobbyist we will soon at earmark you can
see whether he received earmarks to me
this is the the mashing of these data
sets together is really gets you sort of
close to the the holy grail of seeing
then the networks that make up
Washington you know
as you know being able to look up an
individual and who they funded across
the board or the personal investments of
members of Congress and whether they
received campaign contributions from
those interests this will be a very rich
site another example of what we're
building on top of this data is this
site called the national data catalog
known as mad at Kat for short so the
federal government is now releasing has
a plan actually to release all the
federal government data piece by piece
and put it on a site called data.gov we
looked at that and said this is great we
really applaud this however that's just
executive branch data where does the
regulatory branch day to go where does
the Congressional data go where is the
municipal or the state data all of which
is coming online increasing amounts so
we created the national data catalog
which will actually be a catalog the
last site I showed you is a repository
we're bringing all the data in this is
actually going to be a catalog which
will be curated and tagged so that you
can search according to your interest
you can say Kentucky environmental data
city of Louisville and you can see
anything that would have pertained to
that whether it comes from a federal
source or from a state or local county
source again this is this site is in i
would say alpha phase but it is actually
functioning and this is a participatory
source so we're we will be asking
citizens from around the country to
contribute data to this it will be
vetted and but we expected to become a
very rich source as we are seeing a
torrent of new federal data across the
board in terms of issue and topic we are
also to make use of this even easier
building a series of widgets based on
the very same data it's another way to
display it and web services that make it
easier for journalists and bloggers to
add all of these rich resources to their
websites and I would say this is in
pre-alpha lots of things in the pipeline
this work this data focus work really
sloshes over into the second bucket of
our work
which is the development of tools and
websites to enable citizens to quickly
grasp and understand the data one
example of this is our flagship site
called open Congress org this is a joint
project with sunlight and the
participatory politics foundation this
is a site that makes congressional
legislative information easily
accessible because it's all open source
open code we woke up one morning and
found a site which said open mass and it
was all the Massachusetts data just
dumped literally into into this and we
are in the process now of developing an
initial five state based sites like this
as an experiment to see if we can roll
this out to all 50 states or you can go
to a site like this called congre late a
tool where you can mix and match data
sets of your choosing we'll give you a
panoply of them and you can decide what
you want to look at this is called
congre late obviously about
congressional information or a site like
this called capital words and this is a
website that takes the entire
congressional record every single day
and creates an algorithm through by
which they can it can sort and determine
the single most frequently spoken word
of the day and you can use this site to
see what your legislature might have
said on that particular day and you can
search by Congress you can search by
yesterday by month it's actually fun but
also quite interesting because you can
see fascinating political patterns or we
do things that are a little bit more fun
like this which is an augmented reality
app this one we have plotted
recovery.gov projects and you can see
them as you walk down the street I
actually haven't tried it here in Boston
I have it on my iphone but so if you are
interested in what's going on in your
neighborhood you could download you
could look at this we also just plotted
those parties that lawmakers whole hat
are having in the the same augmented
reality
and so if you're walking in Washington
you can see where the parties are we are
into the mobile app space as well this
one is for the iPhone called real-time
Congress I showed this to a member of
Congress earlier this week and he
downloaded it immediately while we were
talking and he looked at it this
provides all kinds of information about
what's happening in Congress right now
he looked at it looked at his staff and
he said I don't need you anymore I'm not
the staff was horrified of course we
have an Android app that's been
downloaded 10,000 times so there's these
do seem to be of some interest and this
is our latest tool for journalists which
is called a recovery Explorer it's not
our prettiest site but it may be among
our most useful so all this data comes
from recovery.gov and in this
application you can actually drill down
to the recipient by state by Department
it's really quite an extraordinary tool
for for reporters sunlight has always
been into the engagement business we we
know and we have we've known from the
very beginning that they're critically
important to our work to the huge task
we have of making government more
transparent our sunlight Labs has
successfully developed and engaged a
community of over 2,000 developers with
government data we've done this through
two apps for America contests and we
just launched our most recent contest
which we should talk about some time
Chris called design for America which is
a proactive attempt to reach out to
designers again to engage with
government with government data our open
house and open Senate projects have
engaged experts and citizens and
identifying easy ways for the house and
the Senate to use technology to become
more transparent and we of course
discover the same thing that Linda has
discovered which is when we do these
lists you know there's the retired X who
spent 25 years
you know working in Congress who knows
you know every rule every regulation and
they now live on the west coast but
through the through the groups that
we've we've developed we can get their
expertise and and help me very much help
contribute to the kinds of things we
advocate for we've we've held to
transparency camps which usually have a
mix of developers government citizen
activists and in fact we have one next
weekend if people are interested in
signing up for it we've launched an
ongoing platform for distributed
research called transparency Corps a
place for citizens to engage in ongoing
research with us and all of these sites
are driven towards nurturing communities
to get them more engaged either directly
themselves or with sunlight and our
latest effort which was actually
launched this afternoon is is this
project a campaign the public equals
online campaign what we hope will
catalyze a transparency movement around
the u.s. of citizens advocating for
online real-time access to government
data much of this work this is supposed
to be a slide of transparent Washington
has the best we could do you know much
of this work it really is is done in a
way to promote a legislative agenda that
we have developed really over the last
couple of years we we like what we do we
like creating databases we like creating
tools and interfaces for citizens but we
actually have this radical notion that
it's government's responsibility to do
it themselves we'll we'll take it in and
push it to the next the next degree but
but government is responsible and so we
have been working very closely and meet
regularly with the staff at the White
House on their open government directive
we work very closely with members of
Congress we have catalyzed a
transparency caucus in Congress which
was just announced
this week and we've helped introduce a
new bill this week a piece of
legislation called the public online
information act and in working with
lawmakers as well to enhance earmark
disclosure you wouldn't be surprised to
hear we favor systemic lobby reform
which means online real-time reporting
and dramatically enhanced online
disclosure of campaign finance
information particularly in the wake of
the recent Supreme Court decision
Citizens United the final bucket of our
work is really to practice what we
preach becoming a media outlet ourselves
that's the eating our own dog food side
of what we do so this is a shot of our
home page we're on our homepage we host
six different blogs with rapid-fire
commentary from maybe eight or nine
different bloggers most of the staff
blogs in one direction or another
another we have one website that's
actually just devoted to our reporting
called the reporting group website and
this is a site that has a number of
interesting features not only a Twitter
stream from the staff of this particular
group but it has a real-time ticker so
as new data is released it actually
appears on this site as well we develop
regular visualizations of our work this
is one that shows senator max baucus's
former staff connections and where they
now work in the pharmaceutical and
healthcare industry got a lot of
attention this is one people who
understand what's happening with the
health care bill using a reconciliation
process a lot of hypocrisy about whether
Republicans voted for bills under
reconciliation or Democrats we said well
let's just do a graphic and so we did so
we see this as part of our own media the
the most exciting thing I think we have
done indeed some have called a
game-changing is what we did during the
health care summit that occurred
recently we called this sunlight live
and apparently we used it again today
so what you see is an embeddable video
of the healthcare summit and to the
right of that we're industry donors to
the person who was speaking so we had an
editor in the room who would put up the
the leading donors to the members of
Congress or how much money they received
from healthcare interest etc constantly
feeding data into this we had a live
blog just below this in which four or
five staff were just throwing data and
throwing information on you onto the
screen and then we had of course the the
tweet stream there and it was an
experiment for sunlight I mean we ended
up one of our staff called it data
jamming because if you watched if
anybody watch the health care debate
what you saw in cable news was you know
who was up and who was down and you know
who was lying who wasn't lying and we
just we just pushed it aside and we said
there is data here we should let the day
to do the talking we had no idea if it
would work but in fact it worked
remarkably well we had 50,000 people
watching the debate on our site we had
nearly 10,000 people participating in
the live blog several several thousand
leaving actually comments are
interacting with us asking us particular
questions we had 1,300 tweets sent out
linking us or linking to us more than
the White House got linked to I might
add and of course if we added up the
number of people reached by those 1,300
tweets it was 25 million people no I'm
sorry it was 2.5 million people even so
a silly number but but I think it gives
you some illustration of how we use
social media to promote what we're doing
that's really an overview of what we do
and I'd be glad to talk about you know
any piece of it in closing I just want
to say that that we believe that the new
technology is pushing the power to the
edges and it may be the only thing that
can challenge or indeed break
Washington's golden rule so thank you
well I want to thank you both for you
know to really riveting talks were
really honored that you could join us
and I guess when I frame the event I had
originally thought that I would frame it
as something like sunlight comes and
essentially takes information from the
top down from the federal in the
governmental level and makes that
accessible to the public and public
inside journalism on the other hand
takes kind of information from the
public pulls it together through
journalists and then you know brings it
back out but in fact you know both of
what you're doing defies that kind of
simple reduction so you know so I found
I find your actual talks of them many
many different ways that the information
is being used and personalized by people
and thought through different social
processes to be really really
interesting I guess I'd start Linda with
a question for you that that you know
actually will be relevant to both of you
probably which is that you describe this
in some ways as a catalyst for
collaboration and and you you talk about
the role the journalists have taken
through this process by you know taking
these stories or feedback from people
and you contrasted with what you call
the catch catch and release model where
a journalist call you know goes through
their rolodex which is often a very
tight rolodex or sometimes you know
reaches into the phone directory and
brings in experts to comment on a
particular you know project and I think
you showed several really interesting
different ways that this goes beyond
that typical what I would maybe call
catch misrepresent and then release
model I'm talking about you wall street
journal but um but but so so you know so
what I curious about though is that um
you know how much do you see this is an
intermediary step I mean do you think
that the the role of journalists is
increasingly changing because you have
access to these databases in the case of
L and she's making a lot of data that
would have taken a lot of work of a
concentrated person to have to go dig
out you know 925 in DC to be able to get
access it increasingly that data is
becoming public and increasingly we're
also seeing that
a lot of news gathering seems to be
happening through distributed means as
you know blogs are doing document dumps
and asking for their own collaborated so
to some degree i'm curious do you see
the role of journalism changing and and
you know does it did you still need the
journalists to that refining and
storytelling or do you see it more as a
collaborative process like in those
smaller newspapers that you started out
in well i do think there's a role for
journalists I think I there's a think
journalism is changing our definition of
journalism is changing but there there's
always a need for sense makers for
people who see and are I mean I think
the problem is is that we have reporters
because of Technology have actually
become in many cases handcuffed to their
deaths and to their computers and
they're not out in their communities and
are not talking to as many people as
they used to and therefore there's an
echo chamber that has developed you know
I spent you know 18 years as a reporter
and as an editor and there's a reason
people have journalists have usual
suspects it's because they vetted them
in many cases they know what their
conflicts of interest are they they know
to some degree when they're both being
there they're bullshitting them and so
they this is and they turn to these
people because they've built some trust
but unfortunately that has really cut
off access so i would say that yes it's
changing and it's changing as we speak
right now so we'll well things always
you know will well citizens just become
their own reporters i don't know i will
say that the people that we talked to in
our network don't want to do our jobs
for us they tell us that they are they
want to be invited into the process and
they want to share what they know and
they're tired of seeing a story on TV or
reading a newspaper on a website and
saying they got it wrong why didn't they
ask me and yet they feel like they have
no no invitation to be part of the
process and I'll just finish by saying
that I am constantly amazed at how
little demands they make on us we're
constantly asking them for near
knowledge and their expertise but even
our own capacity if we use their
insights for every story we do on the
radio it would still
I'll not come close to unearthing the
insights that they've given us rarely
does a source say why wasn't why wasn't
I interviewed by a reporter why didn't
you do a story based on what I told you
they just say thank you for asking thank
you for for listening which is really
key so I think there is a role for
journalists I think it's constantly
changing and they need to be very open
to this idea that there are other people
out there doing what they used to only
be the ones doing so let me just do a
really quick follow-up which is you know
that there's a think we're both founded
funded by the knight Foundation on and
and one of the other projects they
funded was a project called media bugs
which was a very interesting project
that borrows a metaphor from software
design which is a bug tracking system
much like a ticketing system in a lot of
other businesses but basically when
someone has a when their application
crashes or there's something you're
getting a template error on a website
and you can't explain it then basically
you submit a bug and the bug says this
is an open bug it's assigned to someone
and they're basically have to respond to
it and so this media bug project is
basically about how do you actually get
a newspaper to be responsible for things
that they've miss published misinformed
are you finding that this kind of
collaborative approach where you have
this database of people who you have
long term interactions with is forcing
you to be more responsible to your
readers leedy bugs was created because
lots of people send letters the editors
think you got a factual error and
there's never a something published to
acknowledge that by the paper are you
are you finding that that's something
that you are in the situation of less
because you're in more feedback or well
I wish I could say that that we're it
were a total open process that way I in
that yes in some ways just being
available and accessible to people and
having dedicated people in a newsroom
whose job it is to interface with the
public automatically brings that
information closer to the newsroom so
reporters and editors get feedback all
the time they get emails saying you got
this wrong or what have you or maybe the
web editor but when you have a devoted a
person devoted in your newsroom to
really talking and listening to the
public and then they carry that in
I think it does bring a little more
pressure to bear to to correct that
information i will say in the future the
way we envision some of our tools right
now it's a very transactional
relationship that we have with the
public we asked them they respond we see
in the not-too-distant future a much
more transparent form of journalism
almost where people with the insights
can come in and they can actually add to
a story that's already been created even
the people who might have been
interviewed for that story as we all
know reporters take a fraction of what
they get from a source and put it into a
story there's always so much more to the
story why not provide an avenue for
people to come in and say yes and here's
what I here's just another point that i
might add to that and invite the public
it's not quite wikinews but we do think
that there needs to be greater
interaction and greater openness and
transparency just with the journalistic
process um will be taking questions in
about ten minutes or so and so Ellen
this is sort of related but you know as
you're increasingly moving I mean well
so my first question is is there
anything that you guys don't do but it's
a rhetorical question so I'll just move
on so um the second question is you know
you're moving from a space where you're
putting data online and these you know
it looks like you've got a web
application you probably have several
different protocols by which developers
can access it through an API but you're
increasingly saying that you know design
is really critical fostering these
challenges for people design with the
data building designs yourself and I
guess you know I get one of the
questions I had was after you've done
this now for a few years and and have
thought about it for a very long time
what are the principles by which you
think about these designs how do you
recognize what an important design
process is like you showed the augmented
reality iphone app I wouldn't have
thought about that I'm not sure I would
use it or if I would survive crossing
the street if I did but but I guess the
question is what are the kind of design
principles that you've come up with so
far and what are the designs targeted
towards what kinds of attractions are
the best designs targeted towards well
you know they when it comes
to sort of influence data and
understanding the connections the the
web or the you know when my colleagues
used to say if you could inject a dye
into the bloodstream of Washington where
would it flow the interconnections are
so complex that even your best writer
has trouble articulating them in a way
that doesn't lose the most ardent reader
and so for us to the degree we can and
this is one area where we actually are
you know we'll be adding staff this year
is this whole visualization and you know
in from infographic sort of approach to
our work we know we will reach a lot
more people a picture is worth a
thousand words I mean it's that there's
no sort of fundamental principle and
there's really one test in our office
about whether it works if Ellen doesn't
get it within 10 seconds you got to go
back to the drawing board I mean this is
actually it's known as The Ellen test
and it's written in a public wiki so
whenever a new website or visualization
you know is developed I it has to pass
my test and I'm a fairly high end user
but but for us explaining you know
complicated relationships which are at
the heart of Washington or any state
capital through a visualization is
absolutely key and so we're trying to
move more and more in that direction so
I love your analogy of blood in the DA
or die in the blood and and it you know
in the blood stream and it you know
inevitably it ends up in the store but I
you know I think one of the questions
yeah I know that you guys have funded
and I think worked with little sis org
you know which is kind of interesting
because they take this graph node model
of representing these connections which
is of course what the NSA and different
intelligence organizations started doing
after nine eleven moving away from
traditional databases and certainly
looking connective databases and I guess
that that leads to kind of two questions
for me one is what areas of professional
expertise if you if you assume that the
the old user of this data would be an
investigative journalist or a regulator
or someone from a yeah a public
prosecutor what kinds of professional
expertise are you drawing in from
now or looking to drawing from in the
near future well it's um I mean the the
reason for the visualizations i think is
to reach to a more popular citizen
focused audience i mean we we actually
do believe that citizens can go to a
site like transparency data or the next
version of it which is which is more you
know easy both have an easier interface
on it and and and become their own
investigative journalist now they are
not their own investigators not to say
there and being investigative
journalists but the sort of the
combination of under of the availability
of data that come the combining of data
with a combined with social media and
the ability to talk directly to your
legislator sort of says well we should
be designing for this kind of
constituency who will turn around and
send an email or tweet or comment on a
members facebook page and say you just
gave an earmark to corporation x and you
took money from that corporation explain
yourself I mean until you know the
social media became as prevalent and as
part of our daily life for so many
people you couldn't have that sort of
immediacy of it and so that's the kind
of constituencies that we're really
trying to pull towards excellent I have
one more question for you and then we'll
open it up so if I could ask the
audience to use the two microphones on
either side so that the online audience
will be able to hear you later on so the
last question is completely self
indulgent I just want to know what can
we expect from citizen United what how
is that going to change the game she
says with a deep sigh it is very hard to
predict what the supreme court decision
citizens united will have I mean
essentially I don't know if people are
aware of it what it said was that
corporations can spend any amount of
money any way they want directly and
prior to Citizens United there were
barriers set up they had to spend it
through a political action committee or
they had to spend it through another
organ is a
so now they can spend it directly my own
prediction with respect to political
spending is that corporations will not
for the most part get into direct
spending because if I am home depot and
I really don't like you as a candidate
and I spend 250 thousand dollars against
your candidacy I could lose a lot of
business and I don't know how much
business I could lose so I might give it
to the citizens against Chris as a
conduit as a conduit so for us for
someone from sunlights perspective we
must have real online you know real-time
online disclosure so we can follow
actually what the corporations do
whether they do spend it directly or
whether they use conduits spending I
think the most nefarious impact of the
decision might be that the lobbyists
from Home Depot just to use an example
will have an extra something in their
arguments from members of Congress and
if I were a member of Congress knowing
how timid they all are already and I'm
asked to support an amendment I will
think twice or three or four times
before I say no because perhaps this
corporation will go into my district and
spend 250 thousand dollars and try to
knock me off okay great so uh Charles
Tatar could you have a question William
Riccio first there we go okay um what it
strikes me that a core question your
core issue is redaction right the more
information we have the greater the
challenge of trying to parse out what
precisely we need the tools Ellen that
you talked about look great in terms of
helping you know offering a number of
different ways to crack this data and
make something of it and yet we're at a
moment where in terms of public
discourse the things are kind of more
simplistic than ever it's big headlines
its CNN and Fox kinds of highly
simplistic highly polarized debates at a
moment when we have these affordances
that give us a huge amount of data that
require fairly nuanced analytic
strategies and fairly nuanced redaction
all strategies to make some sense out of
them so I guess my question is what do
we
you see these are these are amazing
sources how can we enhance their use how
can we get more people to actually make
critical use of these resources is this
an educational problem is this a problem
of public culture where do you see well
I see barriers to the use of this I mean
you may be satisfied with the numbers
you're getting but if we were to try to
enhance use of this what might me do
where might we look to sort of get a
more alert and active and redaction alee
aware public um terrific questions to
which I do not have the answers I'll say
at the outset clearly the success of
this lies in broader and broader citizen
engagement we have to enlarge the
circles of people who are used to you
know interacting with this information
we have to get it into people's hands
they have to know that it's there when
they want to use it I mean I think the
brilliance of what linda has done has
been to create a community which is
growing I don't know what what rate but
to make sure that there are core users
in each community who know that data and
information you know is available what
we are witnessing with the American
government is a huge cultural
transformation with respect to opening
up their data I mean the nonprofit's are
just learning that they have to open up
their data as well and so I think we
have to understand that the government
holds data that is of interest to us we
were discussing the other day that you
know the department of transportation or
faa has had data on collisions of
airplanes with birds for years who knew
who cared right until we have you know a
plane crash and so the first i think the
first goal least for us is to get the
data there and then to begin to figure
out what's of use to people and direct
people on the director in that direction
it is an educational process for sure if
i can just interviewing for a second
word engagement is a crucial word
important word and yet we're living in
at a moment when there seems to be a
highly engaged public in the the tea
drinkers out there who seem really
resisted who
seemed very good at sort of replicating
a discourse they're given the highly
engaged but not critical highly engaged
but not actually looking carefully at
the data or if they are I don't know
what data they're looking at so um it
strikes me that engagement is a crucial
preliminary stance but it really doesn't
get at least looking at what's happening
right now doesn't seem to get very far
in terms of turning engagement into
critical engagement it's it is a
challenge I would agree with you and and
from from our point of view if you can
put the data out there perhaps you can
change the nature of the conversation
and that's what we were trying to do
through that sunlight live experiment
then if I could just two points one is I
think we could do a better job of asking
people what kind of government
information they want I think we simply
presume because we're interested in
journalists and certain kinds of
information that that's you know what
people really care about and I know that
it's heresay to say this but I'm maybe
maybe there are certain number of people
out there kind of accepted that money
influences politics and we just keep
cramming to them that it shouldn't so I
think we can start by asking people a
little more about what kind of
information they want access to and not
solely just provide them what they ask
for and the second thing is is that
certainly with the creation of budget
hero I mean our idea there was who is
going to read the federal budget not
Congress I mean let alone their
constituents and so but not everyone can
spend a couple hundred thousand dollars
to create a serious game that takes CBO
scoring for all of these public policy
options and then hires reporters to go
out and create the the pro the con and
the social impact statement and then
hire the coders to put it all and then a
designer to put it in some sort of
interactive you know gaming format I
don't know that that's a long-term
strategy but behind it it was make it
make it fun make it interesting give
people information in a way that they
can absorb it and understand it and so I
think what Ellen was saying about data
visualization and some of these other
techniques this isn't just shiny object
you know kind of gadget journalism
there's a real purpose to being able to
deliver information in an engaging way
and in a quick and it doesn't have to be
complicated
during the the Al Franken Norm Coleman
Senate recount that went on and on and
on for months one of the things that
that process did is that it allowed us
to take a look at actual ballots that
are cast which none of us would ever
have access to or maybe even the
inclination to see and because there
were all these disputed ballots so we
were able to take them all put them
online and allow people to be the judge
of who should get the vote and what was
crazy about that is what people do in
the voting booth they draw pictures they
initial things oh I didn't want to vote
for that person if you put any kind of
identifying marks on a ballot it
disqualifies it but who knew that until
we actually until we did a very simple
thing you be the judge we'd show them
the ballot we couldn't figure out who
that person vote for but you would get
to take a crack at it that helped them
understand what those judges were going
through on a daily basis and it cut in
it cut beyond the rhetoric of you know
Franken's doing this and Coleman's doing
that and his campus influence the judges
this way in this way it actually put the
citizen right in the middle of the
process so that would be my answers that
you know we just have to I mean sadly we
do have to make it interesting ryann
o'toole so I thanks for the really
engaging discussion um this questions
for Ellen so you said just now that your
primary purpose is just to get the data
out there and then to figure out how to
direct it or what to do with it and
maybe I missed it and all the websites
that you showed but what kinds of
activities are you supporting that are
more directed I mean there there's this
like politics built into what you're
doing which is about data sharing and
and you know public disclosure but I'm
guessing that gets used by people who
have a variety of conflicting politics
so you know do you support those kinds
of activities you know directly even you
know that now that you're supporting
them indirectly the I could say eua is a
really good point that that our allies
in in the fight for greater government
transparency come from both the
conservative political side of the
spectrum and the liberal side of the
spectrum it's it's fascinating I've
never worked on an issue that that had
that kind of salience
across the political spectrum to date
sunlights funding has been just in two
areas and in its relatively small part
of our budget actually smaller and
smaller part of our budget we have
funded people who digitized data
literally that's what they do some of
the groups that I mentioned and we've
funded people who have interesting ideas
for building tools and websites to
access that data so the project that
Chris referred to little sis org or the
participants foundation create open
Congress some of these are joint effort
some of them are just out and out grants
and to date we have not funded any
activism around using the data but the
campaign that we announced today the
public equals online campaign is really
designed to be a grassroots campaign for
people who want to work on getting
greater government transparency at the
municipal level at the state level at
the federal level and while we will
certainly use that campaign to help
support some of our own legislative
initiatives we will be or at least we're
thinking of making small grants to
people in various communities who have
ideas of ways to pressure their
governments City Council's on up to to
create more transparency whether that's
you know for data or engagement or you
know using technology for collaboration
so we will be looking into that but like
much of what sunlight does you know it
will be an experiment well we'll have to
sort of figure that out as we go along
Charles de tar a question that's
slightly related to his question but so
from an information theory perspective
information is something you don't
necessarily want it's noise I mean white
noise carries more information than
speech for example and if you imagine
the limits of both of the projects
you're working on if you had seven
billion people in your rolodex to call
or if you had high definition video and
audio of every square inch of Washington
and every municipal government all at
once this wouldn't be very useful to
anyone and the thing that's powerful
about what each of you are doing is the
narrative
that get constructed through that data
and so from an aspirational angle or
looking forward to an ideal world who
would you say should be controlling the
narrative and how should they be
controlling that narrative I was going
to see mumbles something about
journalists and so I'm to Linda what you
you know I don't know I don't know who
should control it I should I could say
that I think that it should be more
people who control it now in fact you
know it's it's I'm glad you brought that
that point up people I hear people all
the times they will you know especially
people in the journalism reform movement
that you know journalism needs to be
more like a conversation well I don't
think journalism is a conversation I
don't think it's a lecture either and so
you know I you know I think that there
has to be some people who are paid to do
this work I think some people will be
passionate about it but at some point
it's hard good journalism is hard work
so often the information that we get as
we solicit with some open-ended
questions from people in the network we
don't have people going you ought to
look at this there's a real scandal
going on here there's really something
terrible here or or something we just
have people who tell us stuff that they
don't even know it might be newsworthy
so it takes someone to read that and
kind of have that sense of journalistic
curiosity and then the means both you
know the time and the means to follow up
and figure out where that story really
is so I think that there you know we
need a robust media we need paid
journalists I think you know that's
becoming increasingly more difficult as
news organizations struggle financially
and lay people off I don't know what's
going to fill the void I mean as clay
shirky says you know we're in the middle
of a revolution where the old model has
been tossed out before we know what's
going to replace it so I just don't know
the answer to that and I think I react a
little bit to the notion of who's going
to control this control has been I think
for too long in a very narrow set of
hands who have now lost control and that
is mostly a good thing at least at the
moment it's a good thing that you know
not all you know that not all news flows
through the New York Times and the
Chicago Tribune you know and the
Philadelphia Inquirer so the fact that
there are you know hundreds of thousands
millions of bloggers out there some of
whom nobody's ever heard of but I follow
every day until I get bored with them
and then i get rid of them and i find
somebody else who's writing interesting
stuff to me that is you know it's it's
it's small d democracy and it's very
exciting to see it now you know am I
going to take a fact on something from
an unknown blogger no I'm you know I'm
going to double check it but but this is
a very exciting time you know in you
know sort of the the the civic education
and participation of people and
technologies is what fuels it so I'm I'm
not so I mean I sort of like the fact
that you know control is you know has
moved beyond you know who's going to
control the data well I should control
the data right government should make it
available and I should be able to filter
what I want and there should be easy
ways to search for it so again if I'm
interested in immigration I should be
able to type in a web site immigration
and get all the data about immigration
whether it's you know state-based or
federal base so it's that kind of you
know new approach to you know you know
to lack of control that I think is very
important and very exciting hi I'm I
just want to say that I really respect
in a matter what you're both
accomplishing right now and I think it
really contributes to the shifting
landscapes in our understanding of
information and journalism and I wanted
my question is for you Linda with Public
Insight Network I wanted to understand
in the context of conversations about
citizen journalism and social media
where everything exploded everyone said
everyone's a journalist and I sense a
bit of it back not a backlash but kind
of a coming back to Center where there's
an understanding or a respect that
journalism is a craft and that you need
those voices but they also need to be
more open and more listen listen to
people more as
you say I was wondering with the network
where it seems like people are
submitting their their stories and their
ideas directly I you know from my
understanding of the network and in your
presentation what are the expectations
you find from the people who do submit
their stories do they you you will
mention this a little bit but do they
want follow-up do they want to be
tracked do they want to be notified
credited when their stories are used do
they have an expectation of privacy or
an expectation that you'll share their
information and their names openly and
you know what are the practices that you
and your team have developed to kind of
to navigate this new space and kind of
as a related question how do the
newsroom's handle that are they getting
the message from you guys and are they
adopting the network are they over
adopting it are they using it to relying
on a too much and not getting out enough
and then are they respecting the rules
that you've said in place when they use
it yes to all of that well I'll start by
just explaining a few fundamentals so
not having been around when pij was
formulated but I think I can kind of
figure out what the principles at play
here were it's based on an assumption or
bias toward confidentiality so
everything everyone shares with us is
confidential it's not published unless
they give us explicit permission to do
so and so we get that permission in a
number of ways and now it's also
implicit that a reporter can contact
them it says so in every message that a
reporter or producer make may contact
you to follow up now we don't have
perfect information on all 83,000 people
in the network much you know there are a
certain amount of information they have
to supply an email address and most of
the I mean they can come into the
network through some of the serious
games is a very low barrier to any the
network the key is in the follow up so
for starters every person who who signs
up for the network gets a thank you note
and they generally get a few of the
queries or the kind of journalistic
questions that we might be working on
everyone who responds to a query gets a
thank you note and it's not just sort of
an automatic generated thing it's the
analyst
to who actually issued that query will
provide some synopsis of what came of it
without violating you know when they're
not quoting you know Joe citizen over
here in this community but they're
saying you know here's kind of what we
learned from this query and by the way
here are links to two stories that came
from it so if it actually results in a
story everyone who responded gets a link
gets you know unless it's you know so
far down the line which gets me to the
next part which is how the newsroom's
adopted you know we're seven years in
and we're still we're still learning new
applications and we're still fighting
newsroom cultures I mean the truth is
and this I don't see this ever changing
you know part of the the thrill of
journalism is the aphrodisiac of
discovery it's the reporter knocking on
the door and being invited in and
finding this incredible world on the
other side and the story and they get to
bring that to light and they get to
follow up on it to the extent that
Public Insight journalism does some of
that take some of that away or does that
some of that for them you know there's a
little something lost there so if you're
the journalist on the other side of a
pitch from a story that comes from an
analyst has been talking to a lot of
people you may have ten stories you
can't get to already that may just be
seen as another story on the pile of
what you might want to get to so there's
a lot of salesmanship that goes on in
what we do I mean we have to do we do
reporting we don't just sort of say hey
here's five things people told us do
what you want with them some reporters
and editors truly embrace it again this
idea that you can do prospecting you can
test a hunch as opposed to source
finding which is anyone can say I used
to get these emails as a reporter does
anybody know anyone who and I got this
pic this it was very frightening one day
when I woke up and realized that a
number of stories in the newspaper were
built on journalists and people
journalists knew personally so this is
put an end to that me very no one sends
out emails that say hey does anyone know
anyone who's going through foreclosure
because we have a whole network of
people that we can look for it but but
it gets getting better and it's getting
more exciting the idea that we can use
the network in some incredibly creative
ways you know too
you know we've used a click fix so you
can see click fix I mean Boston did it i
think the globe did a great pothole
project I mean that just makes it very
easy what was interesting about that is
that the public officials who are
responsible for fixing those potholes
get emails and we got a really nasty
email from the public works director and
st. Paul saying I'm getting all of these
emails and tried to go in and kind of
fix all the potholes so you wouldn't get
any more or someone on his staff tin
until they said no you can't do that so
there's a lot of high touch with pij I
don't know if we're going to be able to
sustain that when we get to half a
million people that's why it's really
critical for us to put more control in
the hands of the actual source of the
person out there instead of waiting for
us to email them a survey they have
access and there's some collaborative
filtering that suggests things to them
based on what they've told us about
themselves so and and our strategy is
not to prescribe to newsrooms that use
this tool of these tools in this network
how to do it and then I'll say one final
thing yes it can turn journalists into
lazy journalists because if if all you
have to do is sort of dial a source
whenever you want the idea is it
actually could preclude you from maybe
doing a little more so that's really up
to newsrooms to manage the expectations
and to really think creatively about you
know how they might use this to new news
gathering how many people now staffs the
network well at remote for the most part
outside of American public media
newsrooms it's one analyst one newsroom
in some case it's one analyst to
newsrooms in the case of the st. Louis
beacon they are jointly building a
network and accessing it with ke TC
channel 9 the Miami Herald will be
working in conjunction with wlrn Public
Radio we're now actually next week it'll
this will be announced that the
corporation for public broadcasting is
funding several local journalism centers
which are basically a handful of public
radio stations all who will hire a
reporter to do blogging and reporting
around eight certain topic area so we
have one analyst who will be part of an
agribusiness reporting network in that
case it's one analyst in five
newsrooms so it really depends at
American public media where it was
developed just marketplace the the
business show has three analysts so
that's quite a different ratio and at
minnesota public radio we have four
analysts that in some capacity or doing
something but not all of them are just
querying the network we have one analyst
who does nothing but blog full-time on
the economy based on insights that come
in from people in the network we have
one person who focuses solely on
outreach so if we have if we know we
need to reach people and we have a big
gap in our network we actively go out
and find them Republicans when the
Republican National Convention came to
town we knew we would need more
conservatives so we sought them we
brought them into the tent so it really
depends but for the most part it's kind
of right now one analyst one newsroom
it's cool to hear you guys say that
Democrats and Republicans seem excited
about transparency in government but
transparency seems antagonistic to those
in power can you talk about how you make
a pitch to someone who's in office to
get them to support open records laws
and other transparency efforts or do you
actually leverage that by bribing them
with or you know threatening them with
dirt that you've already uncovered it's
a tough sell I have to say in Congress
um the we often talk about that the
notion that Congress has erected a
firewall around itself and so you know
nothing goes out nothing comes in but
but it's breaking down I mean I think
from our point of view the whole notion
of transparency as a popular position
people in the country like transparent
government when some light was founded
four years ago and we haven't done any
polling we asked a series of questions
about you know would you like to see
members of Congress to slow's this
disclose that etc etc and any everything
we pulled this was a bipartisan
conducted poll and equal number of
Democrats and Republicans responded they
all said yes eighty percent said yes to
everything that we did
possibly we could possibly move so it is
not an easy sell with Congress because
information is power they get that right
and we're asking them to let go of
information which is to release power I
mean it's you know it's not unlike
journalists I mean maybe it's down a
notch or two but you know then the
notion of what do you mean citizens can
actually contribute to my my my
journalism it's a you know it's sort of
a wearing away the fascinating thing for
me because I've spent so many decades in
Washington has been the new
administration's stance with respect to
greater transparency and so we have been
encouraged by them and I actually think
you know I mean I see our strategy
shifting somewhat because the
administration has made a number of very
important steps they're not perfect by
any means and they still do a lot that's
not real transparency but what stuff
that we've put into the category of
transparency theater but we you know it
was day two of the administration when
the President issued a directive and he
said you know give me a memo OMB within
X number of days and tell me how we're
going to use technology for transparency
collaboration and engagement that's a
flag in the ground against which we can
measure progress and so there's there
have been enough positive steps forward
the wind sometimes blows from the White
House down to the Capitol and I think
that with the general cultural change of
how we expect to access information
whether it's you know or make airplane
reservation or order a pair of shoes or
whatever we want to do online the
expectation they'll be able to know more
about the government officials is having
an impact on them you know it the the
argument that we would make is a this is
a good way to connect with your
constituents be people want this you
can't hide from it any longer it's
already public so what we're asking you
to do would just make it public a little
bit faster is it still a bit of a hard
sale I mean one very simple change we
have looked for for our entire four
years is to require senators
to file their campaign finance reports
electronically so we would get them
faster and save a quarter million
dollars a year we cannot get this bill
through the Senate it mean it's
ridiculous and outrageous because of
course they all keep everything bar
napkins or what what are those no no no
I they it's worse than that actually
they they keep their campaign finance
reports on their computers right so it's
digitally available they print them out
they carry them the printed records to
the clerk of the Senate which then
fairies them down to the FEC which then
sends it out to be key punished spending
you know $250,000 and 6-8 weeks in delay
and then now then it's made available
and literally one button you know we
could have it available immediately and
that's a bipartisan resistance so on
that approach we we will be asking later
this year we will try sort of a more
positive approach we're going to saying
you know you can file your reports
electronically if you so choose and so
we'll try to line up a half a dozen
members who are willing to do that and
begin to try to embarrass the others
into moving it since we can't move the
legislation I know that people since the
80s have been basically putting public
data online to kind of force the issue
Carl Malamud and other people and so I
mean I think you would probably describe
your part of what you're doing is
advocacy work by making the data public
to show that it's possible to show that
you know a small not that well funded
organization could do it for a fraction
of the price that in the 1990s a lot of
government agencies basically hired
subcontractors who would you know
value-add the sourcing of public data
you know for charge and so end users
ended up having to pay sometimes small
funds but you know when you're looking
for a lot of data 25 cents per data ms
gets really expensive so how much do you
see this this process of leveraging and
you said your strategy is changing
what's the next strategy after that kind
of prying it open by making stuff public
well we have was an accidental success
we funded mentioned earlier website
called fed spending org
the first publicly available database on
government grants and contracts is a
three-year grant to a non-profit for
three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars and it took them six months to
get the database up and running and it
was a huge success about the same time
they were building that data site a new
piece of legislation was passed
co-sponsored by then senator Obama and
Senator Coburn requiring the federal
government to create a database nearly
identical to the one we had just created
the long involved story about eventually
passed and the very first thing that OMB
did to get their government Ron data set
up no they didn't scrape it they
actually purchase the the license for
assault for the software and so we had
two nearly identical databases and we
still do have two nearly identical
databases the fascinating piece of the
story was that the appropriation to
build the government database was 12
million dollars ours cost three hundred
and twenty thousand dollars so we
thought wow we have a business model
because the nonprofit got six hundred
thousand dollars from the government and
my colleagues and the nonprofit said it
was a nightmare it easily cost us more
than six hundred thousand dollars in
terms of you know the pro bono time to
negotiate with the government so I think
we we do feel that we can kind of show
them how to do this um you know in some
ways and but we're very pleased with the
administration and the steps for where
they're taking even though the future
administration's will be as responsive
to this that is right which is why we're
anxious to pass legislation that
requires all publicly available
information to be online by law because
what the administration do is doing now
is only by directive it could be pulled
it at any moment it will not be in this
administration but it certainly could be
bye-bye future administration's idea
that there's sort of resistance and how
do you get government officials to be to
see the wisdom in in sharing information
I think it depends on what information
you're asking for and also what's your
definition of government if government
is just politicians then
yeah I would agree but government's made
up of you know tens of thousands of men
and women who work every day and are
really proud of the work they do and so
I think we need to think a little more
broadly about who what we're asking for
and who we're asking it of now in terms
of data and spending and all that
absolutely there's a few people who have
their you know who have the keys to the
to the to the safe there or the
combination to the safe and getting them
to sort of make it readily available is
is a real challenge but when you're just
talking about information that that
example I gave about New Hampshire you
know it did not take any convincing to
get town managers around New Hampshire
to submit information about their their
budgets because they saw it as a public
service and they actually appreciated
the radio station being willing to help
them get the word out but it was the
journalists on the other end who
actually looked at the information was
being provided and saw story and then
pursued it so yeah if you're just going
to ask people how much money is someone
giving your campaign you know I think
there's certain kinds of questions that
are going to meet with resistance but
there's a lot of other information and
insight and that we could be seeking
that we're not so taking a very narrow
view of what is government and what
information people might want I think I
mean we've suddenly done a couple of
things one is we sometimes identify what
we describe as low hanging fruit so you
you know you ask for information anybody
goes up sure why not then we had one
campaign which I don't think actually
really worked all that we could claim it
was successful we asked two election
cycles ago we asked members of Congress
to post their official calendars online
to sign a pledge that if they were
elected they would post their official
calendars online we it was it was
fascinating we had 99 challengers signed
the pledge if I'm elected I will post my
of calendar online and zero incumbents
signed the pledge however there must
have been something in the water because
you know at the end of that election
campaign one of those challengers was
elected Kristen Gillibrand she's now the
senator from New York and she continues
to post her calendar online which is
fascinating and now there are a handful
of other seven eight nine ten
of members of Congress who will do that
and the value in that I think is my life
you know is really an open book and so
again you know again this may be
overcoming this cultural resistance that
we talked about but it's some it's not
easy to change you know all the history
about withholding information talking a
little bit earlier about about the
difficulties that there are in getting
the public engaged and wanting to be
active participants and i was wondering
this is a question for linda how you go
about harnessing participation from the
public and whether you run into any
challenges with self selective responses
sure I'm all the responses are self
selected to what we do so we have to
make sure that if we're if we're seeking
information around an issue where
whether it's contentious or not that
we're actively seeking other points of
view and not just I mean we don't take
what we hear from the network and saying
aha that must be the story because a
hundred to one the responses came in
this way versus that way an example for
that would be a few months ago we sent
out a pretty broad base query to
Lutheran's in mostly Minnesota I think
and we asked people how the decision by
the elca to allow actively glade clergy
to serve was affecting them their
congregations and their communities it
was a pretty broad open-ended question
and I don't know we may have sent it to
I mean we we don't ever send one
question to 83,000 people I mean we you
know that would be a nightmare so we
send it to maybe I think a thousand
people in Minnesota or so and we got
2,000 responses so clear there is a
little network effect going on there and
and we found out later just by because
you can you know you can find these
things out that the you know it was kind
of passed along with a little bit of a
push behind it you know advocacy of
people who want to advocate for a
certain position and they want the media
to take notice will say make sure you
fill this out and send it we want them
to hear our voice which is great then we
have to take some extra steps and go out
and actually find people who have the
other point of
and it's actually a pretty good selling
point when you go to an organization and
you say we're hearing a lot of this side
we really want to hear the other side
can you help us get the survey into the
hands of some of the people that you
represent or some of the people we
really want to hear their stories I
think the difference is is that as a
journalist I often had organizations
offered to put me in touch with people
and then I always felt really
uncomfortable that they were kind of
controlling the message behind the
scenes like they'd coach them in this
case they're just posting a link on a
website or sending it out to in a
newsletter and we still get all the raw
responses back so in the other part of
your question was oh about engagement
and getting people to to kind of show up
well it's a strange thing when you ask
people for their thoughts experience
their knowledge on things that they
really care about it doesn't take much
more than that we do beta testing on
subject lines on other things you know
short messages long messages long survey
forms short survey forms we do lots of
different you know we're always looking
at the kind of question that'll really
spark a great response we find the
question tell us a story that helps
illustrate your point of view really
works well people actually will then and
and we've learned a lot of lessons about
yes/no questions often give you yes no
responses so there's some of that about
just getting a certain level of response
back but there are times when we will
send something out we think we'll get a
great response and we get nothing and
there are times when we're really
surprised does that answer your question
sometimes or individuals i mean people
in the network themselves we can contact
them and say we see you know you've told
you you mentioned that you're a member
of these organizations and we're
wondering if you'd be willing to sort of
you know kind of contact them on our
behalf it's often not well here's a
quick example so when Sarah Palin was
the vice presidential nominee she made a
statement that if she were in the White
House that families with special needs
kids would have a friend in the right
White House that really resonated with a
lot of people and we wanted to tap into
that and say wow these people clearly
feel like their stories aren't being
heard so a few months after the election
there was a documentary on special needs
families and special needs kids that was
going to air in a community a few hours
away we didn't have enough advance time
to get someone up to that screening but
we called the filmmaker knowing that
they were probably going to stand on a
stage and introduce their film they had
400 people highly engaged on that issue
and we said hey would you just be
willing to tell them that we want to
know more about this issue and here's
the link and it's on our website just
get up and tell them and within a few
hours of that screening we had 80 people
respond 80 out of 100 s huge response
rate I mean we usually get five to ten
percent on an any given issue but we're
usually sending it to 2,000 people so
that's pretty good you know that's you
know a lot more sources than a
journalist usually talks to on a given
story so a question based curiosity I'm
Ellen so your work is is on publicly
available information and as we
discussed a bit ago that notion of
what's publicly available shifts a
little bit presidential regimes or
whatever and I noticed when you were
running through your slides one of the
headers was information about a dam
project was being banned or something
was a dark spot could you just say
something about the dark areas that
currently exist areas you wish were
currently available that aren't I know
the terrorist this course has been used
a lot to block public photography in
some municipalities that's information
but it's apparently secret information
what sort of stuff what are the odd
things you're finding and what are the
areas you think should be addressed that
are currently dark um we interestingly
we do work mostly with publicly
available information but we're starting
to say that information is not publicly
available unless it's online just let's
get over the fact you know that you know
it's nothing is publicly available if
you have to go to a warehouse in
Maryland and dig through file cabinets
or file a FOIA request even if it's
public information so that's sort of our
starting point but we actually just
funded a joint project with the center
for public integrity in Washington which
we're calling the data mine project to
identify useful information that is not
classified in any fashion and is not
publicly available without a FOIA
request so what you saw on that website
was one of those products and we're
blogging about it twice a week and it I
mean you know you name your agency there
is information that you could imagine
would be of use to someone that's just
not publicly available so identifying it
really comes from I mean the person
who's right who's doing this project for
us over at center for public integrity
is in a long time investigative
journalist and you know through you know
through his telephone calls information
gathering for particular stories he ran
into a data set and he said my god I
never knew that existed so one of the
things that we said very early on to the
administration which they did take to
heart is every agency has to account for
us to do a full audit of the data they
collect and how they collect it and how
it's made available because nobody knows
I mean the agencies don't know right so
this little pocket in this agency may be
collecting x y&z but nobody knows what
they're really collecting especially if
it immediately is I mean if it's filed
on paper and then filed you know in a
manila folder and then shipped off to a
warehouse in Maryland so our
understanding is that as a result of the
open government directive on april sixth
or seventh we will have a list of we
will have that audit agency by agency
the data that's collected and how it's
made available and then they're supposed
to be some priority set for how they
move that to being available online
including with public input into that on
the the agency's open government website
pages so they're asking for public input
which is a good thing because the the
very first piece of the directive
ordered all the agencies to put three
high-value data sets on two day to gov
after the first 45 or 60 days which
agencies did we looked at these and we
said huh the wild horse population from
the Interior Department is a high-value
data set to whom we say what what is
with that and then there were some other
things they were equally ridiculous and
then we turned around the government we
said look guys the term high-value data
set just do away with it because maybe
we're wrong maybe wild horse population
information is a high-value data set but
you got to justify it someone may want
to know that but is it just someone so
inviting the public in to participate
and say okay here's our laundry list
what do you think is high value and
while again it's not a statistical
sample you'll get some sense of you know
anything that deals with perhaps health
and safety would be high value you know
to to an interested citizen so I think
they're beginning to work through this
but it is it's it's not an easy process
but it starts with an audit so we know
what's available I was in Phoenix
recently went to a spring training game
with my brother who's a vice president
of a local hospital I just said hey Doug
what kind of information do you have to
report to the state do you have to
report all adverse incidents I mean it's
just he's to tell me but I think
sometimes you can ask people who work in
jobs that you think might have to report
something to government and then you
have a sense of what government has so
there's you can you know there's sort of
the there's that route but I mean that's
the thing i mean we probably have no
idea what information is locked away
that would be
nating and I think it starts by you know
finding out what do you want to know and
who do you want to know it from and then
trying to find those people and gather
that kind of information then there
there are clearly categories of
deliberate not deliberately withholding
information so there's a lot of drug
testing information there's a lot of
information out of the FDA over you know
this device or that device that are
tested it's not secret information they
do not publish it so we but we need to
know what it is before we can request it
you don't know what you don't know
that's it that's a great segue to a
question that I had which is you talked
about the fact that the data is not
provided its its data that is on the
operations of private institutions of
pharma companies or so I guess the
question for me is that we're seeing
radical shifts in public and private
data you know there were these
safeguards put in place with things like
social security numbers to say we want
to you know prevent corporations from
being able to use data about people that
are gathered by the government but in
fact at this point corporations have far
more data about people in the private
record then then the government does so
you talked about how politicians are you
know you want to be able to tell where
they're bottled water and their flowers
are going MasterCard has that data for
me right now and I'm not in the in the
public domain so how do you approach
this question of public and private data
I mean obviously your mandate is on the
public data but increasingly we're
seeing real changes in people's
lifestyles where you know i'm not
actually surprised that new politicians
are better about posting their calendar
online because in fact that's a choice
that like 14 year olds are making
non-stop you know so you won't actually
have to go and photograph them with
their mistresses you could you know
they'll be posting on facebook so so the
question the question then is you know
how do you see as the shift between data
ownership between private and public is
switched shifted so much how do you see
that relationship and do you think
there's any room for an organization
that concentrates on that well there is
um I mean we're certainly well aware of
the privacy concerns you know private
information that may be
you know collected by a corporation
let's say it was you know testing you
know a new device that was implanted in
people to do X and it might have the
patient's name there I don't actually
know whether the patient's name on whom
the device was tested is reported to the
fda I don't know that but let's assume
for the moment it is because they may
need to track that person in case
there's ever a recall or problem or
update obviously we have to ensure that
privacy information you know is redacted
from the from the information and then
we have to trust government that what
they have redacted is actually
appropriate the moment I don't think any
of us you know have that level of trust
i mean there's an interesting story the
white house visitor logs the
administration is doing this voluntarily
and they said we will post them but
we'll take I think it's 90 to 120 days
to scrub them because when you go into
the White House you do give them your
birthdate and your social security
number and your place of birth so
obviously they said we don't want that
information we will make sure all that
gets taken out and then they said and
then we'll redact that or withhold
information from for people who are
visiting the first family their personal
friends and anyone else where national
security might be compromised like whoa
so this is a funny story so I have a
daughter who's doing a graduate class at
NYU and she decides she's going to
review the White House visitor logs and
I see her post at the end of the
assignment and she says you know we have
no idea how many people have been
redacted we don't know if it's a hundred
a month or if it's 500 a month the
electronic document
it's a problem with the electronic
document side and I thought that was a
stunningly good point which I then
raised with the folks at the White House
to which they have not responded yet so
I so I think you know it's acted I mean
yeah there was it response was unspoken
or unprintable so I think you know we
are all moving into this era you know
sort of step by step and I think what
you know we are realizing is it's okay
to try something and not have it work
it's okay to have to try something like
recovery.gov and get data on the
stimulus projects and then realize that
some of the garbage is just some of the
data is just garbage but it raises the
issue of what are we doing about data
quality how do we ensure that the
numbers are right and this this is a
remarkable conversation to be having I
don't care whether the data is perfectly
clean but to actually see government
saying how do we do this how do we do it
in a way it's responsible how do we do
it in a way that's trustworthy how do we
do it in a way where the data is is
cleaned and available we've never had
this discussion before and I think it
really is part of everything that
happens in Washington right now you set
me up really well because I just have to
know what do you have on all these
people that they seem to listen to you I
mean is this is how you seem to really
have influence and access in order to
make not only request for data but
demands on what should be in that data
set and I'm curious what the sunlight
foundation and what your leverages in
all of this I'd like to say it's all us
but I have to say it's a confluence of
ideas we we have a wonderful chart which
I didn't show you today of the mentions
of the word transparency for the last 20
years in the New York Times so one of
our data visualizers did this great
chart and I asked him last night to
double check the numbers when sunlight
started in 2006 I think the number was
something like 410 mentions of the word
transparency in the New York Times and
last year it was nearly double that I'd
like of course to take full credit for
that I can't it
is I think I said this earlier it is a
cultural shift that's happening you know
we expect stuff in real time I want to
know what the weather is I want to you
know contact my other daughter I do it
by text messaging I you know it's
government is is playing catch-up I
think to where the rest of us have moved
in terms of you know real-time
information and how we live our lives
online so I'd like to say that some
lights fully responsible for it but but
we're not I guess I me kind of follow up
in on that too i'm just i'm curious
whether you have like who are the
advocates within government that are
communicating most with you are most
receptive to your mission politicians
but also within the different
departments I'm other particular
Department so you're speaking with more
and then related to that also we're
talking about who controls information
what gets released how much in the
designing of your of your you know your
your transparency kind of platforms are
you also thinking about getting
information that's not publicly
available but that could be made
publicly available people within in
government who want to leak information
whistleblowers or other people large
community of nonprofits in Washington
who have been in I would say the the
public information space there's
actually a coalition called the open the
government coalition and I believe it
has something like 50 or 70 members at
different nonprofits who have joined it
it's it's a you know it's it's it is a
coalition it is fought in the past
mostly on FOIA related issues within
that there are probably five or six
major organizations who are part of the
constant you know discussions arguments
lobbing that goes on both on Capitol
Hill and in the White House what the
administration did which was rather
remarkable as they appointed a federal
CIO who was the former dcct oh man by
the name of the vet Kundra who
understands this space and understands
seems to understand that the politics of
how you you move people who are not you
know like the people who report to him
into this space to understand why this
is important for delivering services why
it's important for Economic Development
why it's important for democracy and so
he has been a terrific leader alongside
the federal CT 0 which is a brand new
position which is headed by Aneesh
Chopra who likewise really understands
this space and so they along with the
white house ethics council norm Eisen
and the head of the regulatory section
of OMB Cass Sunstein have formed a kind
of very close group which have been
driving these white house based
initiatives and that's that's tremendous
it makes all the difference in the world
on the hill the Allies come from across
you know across the spectrum one of the
early users of social media is one of
the most conservative congressman from
Texas his name is John Culberson and you
know you know direct tweeting me you
know at seven thirty in the morning
quick you know a quick viewing whatever
it's called you know all of his meetings
his conferences and he gets a lot of
attention for it and he gets a lot of
kudos for it and so other people look
over their shoulder they go wow maybe I
should do that you know to Nancy Pelosi
who has a very active blog who really
understands the space and has been in
Terraria instrumental in some of the big
successes we've had like getting the
White House expenditure reports online
so there are a lot of allies both in the
house and the Senate the transparency
caucus that's about to be introduced one
of the most conservative members aissa
from California one of the most recent
freshmen members Quigley Democrat from
Illinois that's actually Rahm Emanuel
seat I mean you just like you see these
strange bedfellow things happening all
the time so it's it's fine people who
want to be leaders in this space we find
a lot of Republicans calling for a lot
of transparency now that they're out of
power
and but there are plenty of Democrats
you know who call for it as well so we
we try to walk this fine line between
both of them to get something that
really does make sense I have a question
how how do you deal or how do they deal
with transparency when so much of what
Congress has has always been protected
from FOIA so some of their own records
and things like that so I'm wondering do
we are we going to see a big change in
that well we have said that FOIA for
Congress is you know is certainly in our
certainly in our sights I think it would
be a long time coming actually so the
Congress is more resistant to this trend
then the administration has been there
is absolutely no question about it so
that's why we want to try some of the
more positive things and making sure the
members who use social media who do
communicate directly get the rules
committee to change the rules about you
know how they can use social media so we
launched until a year or so ago maybe 18
months or so ago members of Congress
were actually forbidden from using
social media on their websites so we
launched a let our Congress tweet
campaign I don't know coincidence or not
they were already thinking about
changing the rules for two weeks later
they changed the rules so members can
actually tweet from the House floor and
use video and have you know interactive
sections of their websites so it's you
know it's just pushing open the door you
know a little bit at a time talked about
but also in state a lacrosse I mean
there you're really seeing because
silicon valley seem to contribute quite
a bit to the Obama campaign they're a
bunch of people at all kind of levels of
the federal government now who represent
the concerns of Google and other
organizations like that and of course
every every time you get someone from
industry who takes a turn in government
they create a government that's going to
be a little bit better for them and so I
find this really kind of an interesting
side effective is it is fascinating to I
mean State Department under a lacrosse's
leadership is has been terrific and
they're doing really amazing stuff and
so you know we can professor in yet but
but they're trying really hard
they're trying and I think the fact that
government is being allowed that people
inside government are allowed to become
experimental the same way that we on the
outside just like well try that didn't
work or we tried that and wow what a
success that's that it represents pretty
much of a major transformation in the
way that button down government usually
works and certainly states I mean there
are a number of states out there I think
who with without pressure from
organizations like sunlight or anyone
else are just sort of doing some of this
on their own they may not be doing it
quite to this extent but I know when I
was in Utah you know all campaign
contributions are electronic they're
searchable you can follow legislation
you can sign up for email alerts every
time a bill is amended so there you know
I think it would be wrong that the
assumption that is all the call
government wants to keep all government
information secret but there certainly
you know there's enough resistance out
there to make us cautious but and enough
cities now have made like DC has made
their information available san
Francisco has made their information
available I'm trying to think I know
that there are at least another half a
dozen cities that are moving in the same
direction following DC in San Francisco
so that citizens can have access to
information that they want whether it's
information on bus stops or city parks
that need repair or you know whatever
that in all information is if we answer
your question on whistleblowing though
yeah just doesn't does the second
question was just on leaks and
whistleblowing to what extent are you
thinking about strengthening the role of
internal you know agents of um doesn't
really deal in the whistle blowing you
know the sort of that that that method
for reporting information but one of our
closest colleague organization does the
Project on Government Oversight has a
series of recommendations with respect
to whistleblower protections to protect
them they also deal in the area of
government contracting and oversight in
that arena as well so I'm going to have
to call an end to this but i just want
to mention that we have a reception
upstairs at the rd cafe and assuming
that some of you have kids to get home
to i think we have enough drinks for
everyone
so so please come up to the please come
upstairs I also wanted to mention i mean
if there had been more time i actually
would have asked them you both about
taking these models that are working
really well in the United States
internationally and the State Department
seemed like a good segue but we won't
have time for that but so the the segue
that I'll make is that April fifteenth
we have a another communications forum
this will be hosted by Ethan zukerman if
you don't know him he runs global voices
or was involved in the founding of
global voices start you found a geek or
the kind of a peace corps for for geeks
and is is really tied into a lot of
these questions about transparency
accountability citizen journalism
internationally and so that session is
going to be quite different he's
basically going to be bringing in by
Skype people from around the world for
like five or ten minutes sections people
are involved in the Twitter revolution
in Moldova or in Iran people are
involved in developing Ushahidi and
Kenya so it's going to be kind of a
low-res everyone's going to sound like
robots but but a very very wide cast
question about Civic Media in different
places April fifteenth same time same
place so thank you so much for coming
out and come on up and have a drink with
us
you